Audie is with us in Peoria IRT welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show well thank you
very much for having me on for the work
that you do thank you how can I help
well I have a little different situation
than you usually have but when I heard
that millionaires scream I thought well
even at 81 and my fiance is 84
he's been where were about three years
I've been a widow for over 30 and we
used to work together many years ago and
we have decided after a year of dating
that we will get married and so I was
officially engaged Valentine's Day and
more an engagement that I wear an
engagement ring so there is my
background situation that's dream fun
well this is the situation when I
accepted the engagement ring I had to
accept it with condition because we have
to we had a number of thing issues of
course at our age with children and
grandchildren and great-grandchildren we
needed to make sure first of all that
everything was copacetic with my our
children and that's the problem sauce
not a problem at all both sides of the
family have just gently said I think
actually they said oh good mom monka
somebody's take care of her and he says
family said oh good dad just let me take
care of his you can stir we are we have
health issues and a lot of those things
have to be taken care of and then we
also needed to know where do we live and
how do we do our budget we are very
differently we have a very different
perspective I had a family of seven of
five children and my husband and I I was
mostly a home mom till I went back to
college and got my teaching degree and
he is always meant a teacher
and now that we're retired Easter
substitute I had had a job up until 2050
and I still work and we are pretty hard
workers but we have had some health
issues so those have to be dealt with
and so we have not said a wedding day
everybody
I best help you today ok these are the
two questions really that we need to
deal with this we have a very good
income and command set we won't be
hurting at all but there are some
questions about one how do we set up
means of deciding what our living
expenses will lead and how much you
should we invest in a home to live in
he has an older home that will require a
good a good amount of money to renovate
and so how much money do you have and
how much money does he have well he has
what 3 times the same 3 times my
retirement is about 28,000 a year I mean
my income yeah knot-tying
accounting income do you have mistakes
nest eggs or net worth okay well I have
I have about 80,000 is mine SSS but I
have a twenty thousand dollar mortgage
still on my house because I have to
upgrades I'm actually in the process
what is his work what's he done he has a
small farm and it's worth about well
it's probably when that is right now
over for that four hundred thousand okay
what I would tell you to do and what I
tell all young couples to do on the
household budget is to do a budget and
lay it out together and you guys figure
out together what you're gonna spend on
your household budget you've got your
incomes in front of you and you can
spend all all of that income if you want
to there's no problem with that
I would love to see you sell off a
couple of these odds and ends pieces of
real estate and end up with a paid-for
property that the two of you are living
in said that you've got the piece of
that and I would like that to be left to
the person that is survived when one of
you passes the other one ends up with
that house you can do whatever you want
but that's what I would want for my wife
our husband where I exactly in your
situation the rest of the assets then
you should be left to probably to your
kids or his kids his assets to his kids
your assets to your kids this is one of
the rare instances that I would say to a
prenup yes yes exactly just
coincidentally before we started dating
had decided our will we both had Donna
and they fit perfectly our two lawyers
his lawyer would like to eat me and
president McQueen up which is really
because he has many more assets than I
do
and they also go to his children well I
think that's great and I think almost
all of them should go to his children
but he's you know and love-- enough with
you to marry you so he also is going to
want to make sure you're okay well my
house was always for the last year for
years I've been doing things to my house
to put it on the market because I was
planning before I met him and when we
started dating and married that I would
I wouldn't swear my children live okay
you can use that money out of the sale
of that house to be your nest egg and
you've got a prenup to protect your
money flow into your kids his money
flowing to his kids and grandkids and
with the exception maybe of the personal
residence where maybe that is one of the
things he gives you now maybe if he were
to Pyat pree decease you were to pass
first maybe you would sell that move to
Texas spill but that's still one way
that that you would slightly benefit
financially from the marriage and he
could do the same exact thing were you
before him he would get that house and
if you put a little bit of your money
into that house that wouldn't be a bad
thing so you can work that out you don't
have to do that it's just an idea that I
threw out but in marriages at this age I
think a prenup where there's assets is
always a good idea because it keeps
everything real clean and there's no no
weirdness in the family because families
get weird about these things so normally
I do not recommend a prenup accepting
extreme wealth situations but in this
case this is the type of thing where if
I were in your shoes I would and if he
if I were in his shoes I would so what's
an honor to talk to y'all D I'm so
excited for you guys congratulations and
I hope you guys get this lined out and
get this date set up fast that's what
you need to do I love it very fun stuff
hey thank you for calling in